I'm not sure the science supports this
yet hi I'm a PhD in Medicinal Chemistry
and this is not a good idea some people
have already mentioned that tretinoin is
not stable with light and air but did
you know that it is also chemically
unstable that means that some
ingredients can actually break down
tretinoin faster especially in
combination with light and air if it's
broken down then it stops working and in
this study they found that the
formulation was really important one
example is this ingredient Bridge 35s
which is a pretty common surfactant this
broke down tretinoin faster but on top
of all that preservative stuff that I'm
always warning people about having lots
of mold growing in your product there's
also the fact that you're probably
wasting most of your tube of tretinoin
this way it's just much safer to mix it
in your hand right before you apply it
also if you're pregnant or you're trying
to get pregnant I wouldn't recommend
doing this tretinoin can theoretically
cause birth defects and the Chance is
higher if you're using it on a bigger
surface area your whole body rather than
just your face